[Music]
the sequel immediately trolled its
audience with its production logo so the
rad code right we got a six military bad
guys wait until agent farmer was able to
squeeze off a warning to his superiors
instead of killing him before he
discovered his dead courts discount Nick
Fury even we love unarmed office lady
decides to leave the relative security
of her walled cubicle to wander into a
hallway with no cover soldier is way
more USS enterprise but I think the
movie intended even though Givens put
the bunker on lockdown these giant doors
remain open I really think she's
everywhere they've covered all the hall
actually you know they've only blocked
about half the halls so unless this
underground bunker only has one entrance
and exit you've got some outs highly
trained security agent Gibbons just lets
this little flying camera look right out
and long enough to gather information
about who use and is whereabouts in the
bunker ah where the are they going to go
they lock this room down so the only way
out of here is through the large men
with guns maybe just say bend over and
kiss your ass good-bye
so now is this off this time sir then
diesel Gibbons and shavers escaped
without even one of those heavily armed
assholes chasing after them the new xxx
has got to be more dangerous deadly Adam
that's Gibbons focus on attitude instead
of security and research and development
is why he just left behind dozens of
murdered colleagues and state secrets
also Gibbons is already looking for the
next xxx even before he realizes the
first one is dead also sure the first
xxx had some sort of purpose to be a new
goddamn superhero but at this point in
the franchise we'll just take anything
ex-military that's previously worked
with us almost a minute and a half of
grandiose mission impossible x-men James
Bond style credits to pad the runtime of
a mercifully short movie yes I know
might be sequel to a hit movie logic
will Dafoe is going to speed to cruise
control this movie as the villain this
is a laundry list of suspects that
covers half the world well you better
get cracking on it instead of standing
around expositor about a legislative
MacGuffin society please
okay so I encourage on fact if you play
a Jedi in a Star Wars movie you retain
Jedi mind-trick towers and all the other
movies you're in which explains why
discard just leaves without questioning
whether Givens is actually dismantle
order I always tell the ones that we
captured in the wild I don't look in
their eyes well it's cute how even after
all this time they still complete each
other's sentences also this is a
masterclass on my Ice Cube should have
continued his rap career I liked what
she did with chips
Darius burns given so hard well it was
very perfect but that was sick also
that's faces should any job at the NSA
have enormous ly identifiable writing on
the uniform standard cage was killed in
bora-bora last night Jerry's dead until
it becomes financially relevant for him
to come back he was one of only three
men with access to that elevator you
know the one that leads to sweet escape
from the death bunker and has been in
plain sight of all the other NSA staff
the other two and can medium inasmuch
savings wait what about shavers who was
hiding in the garage he had to have that
access it should be an accounted for -
just to prison architect if you want to
keep your prisoners from escaping remove
the design flaw of the rigid pole right
next to the door handle that is an
impediment to inmate chasing key and
under that bed he just kicked through
seems to have magical regenerative
powers because it is now completely
intact the plaintive wail of the one
guard who truly loved him was drowned
out by Darius's obligation to his
country nobody noticed this booking
helicopter until right the second to get
in shape for this role cube did ten
bicep curls before the shot and called
it a day
nice huh you just escaped at 12:04 get
and said 1206 was the extraction and
that was literally the only moment you
could have hopped on the chopper so this
seems more like an excuse to deliver a
stupid action movie line you know the
police have helicopters to Jesus Gibbons
has the ability to flee the scene of all
major disasters without anyone pursuing
it she had large and extra-large but do
you have a triple XL serious song cell
block a not anymore Darius stone no
longer exists but how all the guards in
the prison he just escaped no he exists
and the NSA later pulls his entire file
you're the new xxx porno star for what
happens at all xxx
he's dead yeah but that just happened
last night and given to us and busy
preparing this Prison Break on his own
so how did he hear about it especially
you know what temp being outside of the
NSA and everything we need to go to work
now I need to give him a surprise in
another shake somehow the conversation
between cube and his personal trainer
made it into the script what else can
you do last xxx he could ski surf
through all kinds of stuff
this is an excellent question Gibbons
means the next xxx to be in deep cover
and use non-traditional methods so of
course he picks a career military
asshole no special skills
rain we gonna need something any media
most ironically the person who said this
in a pre testing meeting was immediately
fired yeah he nation will start by
giving me some Darius has gone with
these people from Leavenworth Kansas all
the way across the country to Washington
DC and have
Anto tube is former associates of chop
shops without knowing a thing about the
mission make that into a personal aim
you know discount Scotty Jason no you
haven't told them anything about the
Commission besides the next location
just on intelligence compound is teeming
with agents none of them think to look
at the road where there's a
conspicuously tricked-out truck
containing a dude with binoculars you
can hold the floor everybody else follow
me there are dozens of NSA troops on the
farm but agent underworld leaves only
two assholes to guard the actual agency
compound
Tereus drops in through this hole that's
left completely open to move with
impunity into a bunker of its similarly
unguarded so he should be called mission
reasonable and main room even though
Gibbons and stone went over a layout of
the bunker the night before movie still
finds it necessary to have shavers walk
him through navigating the NSA bunker
free drive space oh you're telling me
the NSA didn't already take the hard
drives from the secret location also how
long are these agents just going to hang
around this crime scene get into went
all the way to Kansas wait until the
next day to get Darius out then it took
at least another day for them to get
back to DC then they off lucky for stone
these boats still have the keys in them
no one's really starting to miss the old
circle oh jesus this movie is hammering
the fact that Ice Cube has not been
diesel okay he's not a muscle-bound job
but could then make it was a good day
humble Wow I hope they use extra Elmer's
glue on that boat before stuff like this
top guy realizes that it's in this movie
and takes the smart way out by bursting
into flames and jumping into the river
trance Knifer the highest dive in navy
history and we needed to give him some
sort of extreme ability so that we could
justify spending 90 million on this
piece of footage we have on them a
meeting with his lawyer okay this is the
NS King a but no one recognized the
wanted former agent that's m.i.a and
this footage till now breeze it blow it
up zoom an enhance cliche as a drink I
took the liberty of pour well without
faking liberties Gibbons mistakenly
thinks he has a pawn pointed at is head
and never ask you to go into that fire
no you just sit it in watch it all right
you know what this foreigner is about an
X Games athlete turned government spook
needs wartime backstory just so you know
but every year up to did not get away
with it thankfully this is what the box
office said to this movie Darius stone
is going to stop me
is that supposed to be a surprise this
is a legitimate question given
flamboyantly broke him out of prison and
several dozen people saw stone
inexplicably blow up a bunch of
different modes of transportation they
haven't exactly been subtle about it
make it look like an accident
it's not that I'm mad the villain leaves
this highly trained super agent in the
hands of a minor henchmen it's more but
I don't give a thousand Augustus given
was a former Navy captain wait are they
just sitting around watching the news
and this came on now also they have
known that went down as the NSA FBI
Joint Chiefs Secretary of State but
apparently there's no security detail
around them that would notice one of the
most wanted men in the country several
yards away also earlier agent Kate
Beckinsale's booty-call said they were
going after Givens meaning he dissented
on rogue and was not in the good graces
of the government but the Secretary of
State shows up to his funeral
sharni you found her this is the only
way they could find the person named
curly on the microfiche thingy they
found on the drive go to get into the
funeral and find a hottest chick there
and look for a guy like me it was nice
like this unless they were you know
following up on all the lead from
Gibbons like they literally said they
would do a few minutes ago stay drinking
and the aid to the system
Terry action terrific this action
thriller threw in some political
intrigue that is not their political
more intriguing Cassio Younis
and none of them recognize you he does
we generally was talking to Jack's
Pentagon as if this poor bastard were
insulted enough by Darius the
screenwriters had to name him after a
spiteful erection we go back 30s Jack
never questioned my command
Decker continues his bad guy in cliche
bukakke by expositing right in the
middle of a goddamn party once we lead
the full force will follow willem dafoe
submits his Star Wars audition be a
triple x equals black guy white time no
white girl dinner jacket Jesus can't
this movie get anything right huh
surprise on the shake I'll take sexual
innuendo that will make you hungry for
four hundred Alex highly-trained
professional killer sees a random gun on
the floor and immediately picks it up I
don't care how important this dead guy
is they're sending ridiculous blues
brothers Ian levels of cop cars for this
hangout I don't care who you are you got
six minutes to we preach wait they think
the Chairman's still in there though
right they still come up with a
hilariously arbitrary deadline for
breaching the house I got him
looks like upstairs bathroom earlier we
saw Darius microwaving various frozen
dinner and meats to throw off the heat
signature but Kenley's can't seriously
not tell the difference between a
banquet meal and a human being at one
point after watching a million movies
where people assume the SWAT members
uniforms to conceal their identities do
they think about doing away with the
masks this TV gets more screen time than
Samuel Jackson and Bowie you know you
know she really doesn't have to do
anything this woman just gave him a
place to crash our exhibit booted him
out and now she's mixed up in the
military coup but somehow looks like she
ingested half a bottle of xanax you live
on a damage we did in back see the
literal American armed forces are coming
after Darius but he's going to reminisce
about the booty he got his old Mustang
for several minutes mmm D it should be
noted that more people called areas DS
and X and a movie title xxx
to USS independence in an aircraft
carrier man agent I forget his name has
to explain to a Navy veteran what a
naval ship is 23 goddamn seconds of Ice
Cube and a wit soup climbing a chain
this is Anna Ken Burns documentary or
anything movies only 95 minutes dude has
top-secret documentation out in view of
any of these assholes
Jesus don't these bad guys have any dark
hallways or closets to do their business
in thankfully another one has four
special black vinyl villain suit for
easy identification
yeah Givens has a point leaving her
behind we'll definitely come back to
bite ice and his cubes well you guys
have pretty much the same weaponry so
he's running you into that helicopter
right there Jesus it's like these guys
have never cank before no one takes a
clear shot at Darius here because like
me they didn't think he could actually
pull himself up like God issues actually
getting into the fight and instead
stands around like a dickhole yelling
into the walkie-talkie yeah sergeant
Cobb summarizes the experience of
watching this movie what exactly did
Darius hope to accomplish on this
mission to the carrier even he couldn't
have thought this movie was stupid
enough to allow someone to just have
obvious top-secret Intel on their person
that he could just whip out of their
pocket magic water bullets are not quite
magic enough to hit a sizeable target ah
quad via the NSA is in the middle of a
massive manhunt but agent dude that dumb
Felicity has time for a goddamn boxing
match you're not World War 4 I think
stone lost count of his world wars what
did you wrong I was wrong but she was
more than just another stone gets all
pissy about Steel reasonably questioning
his conspiracy theory about the
Secretary of Defense plotting to kill
the president dude the entirety of the
US government is looking for Darius but
this one guy tracks him down in a matter
of minutes can he be the next xxx
president VP bigger the house secondary
estate the chain of command actually no
first off it's the chain of succession
not the chain of command second it goes
from the president to vice president
then Speaker of the House president pro
tempore of the Senate Secretary of State
Secretary of Treasury then Secretary of
Defense so this little civics lesson is
wrong but hey who would have expected
the screenwriters to do a five-second
Google search ha side two bucks are you
prepared to go like cast a husky rapper
at the lead in your action franchise
vehicle parks absolutely no go get it
the best exhibit names the two things
that had to be rubbed the greenlight
this movie I guess I'm stuck I know
you're gonna love okay I know they've
been set up at this chop shop for a
couple of days but shavers does happen
to cue a bunch of bulls up in his spare
time Darius and his crew hijack a truck
with government artillery in broad
daylight
isn't anyone keeping an eye on this
vehicle is an engine
what can men do well if that man were
say been diesel we'd be a little more
work the fate of the free world in the
hands of a bunch of huncles and see
darius makes a similar comment to a
typical Facebook post by my aunt Debbie
hi yeah Ron yeah I'm not as annoyed by
the stupid white boy moment as I am that
this is the only character that calls
Darius X wow this State of the Union
address is pretty sparsely attended I
guess Congress got stuck in traffic or
something oh yeah is there a way to
convey an eye-roll via text and audio no
damn that's true it blew up blew up and
they all survived this welcome to the
first paint jacket in history and it's
amazing that none of the other military
assholes are around us you got us
sure you know how to drive this thing
trying to get a feel for but you just
expertly maneuvered a tank on the
aircraft carrier right not as the
president not killed like everyone else
even accidentally get rid of him let's
do it all slow and you know how I like
it
this asshole trying to break down a door
into the Capitol while his partners
prepare to blow a hole in the side of it
as almost made launching this movie
worthwhile juicy 6y1 teams well or you
could just shoot at these two kids that
are standing out the open guns bullets
darkness excitement underground
presidential bullet drain forgets to
underground get in - is that supposed to
be a traitor and that were supposed to
be dead orders the goddamn Capitol
police and military around and nobody
questions him movie apparently blue it's
a sex budget on the prison escape
Sam Jackson got the crew from deep blue
sea to do the rest in exchange for free
coffee and bagel of all the preposterous
in this movie this is the preposterous
feast
she's either think to yourself hey do
you think a sports car would go as fast
as a bullet train if the tires blew out
it was riding on the rims of a rail
track if so congratulations you wrote
this movie darius waits until just now
to reload sorry I had some brain leaked
out of my ear what was I saying oh yes
the old combat method of hiding inside
the upper kitchen cabinet to defeat your
foe it's in some zoos are worn
everything thank you actually it's been
nine but at this point is anyone still
paying attention but me also Deckard has
a massive pregnant pause before killing
someone problem is she Darius attended
the Prometheus school was swimming away
from things son of a bitch stole my life
and you stole this one from Robin
Williams and good more hunting I think
we need to go even further off the grid
next
I've got the perfect candidate Lancey
rent also sure lot to wait for 12 years
and Babylon ad the past but stay patient
I'll never have dinner with the
president you got to go off the grid now
but if you want to stay and hit me you
need to keep both eyes open
[Music]
you happy visit yeah jacket takes over
freedom will be free for freedom and and
free it called folks like day with me I
was having me I come today
good I'm ready here I'm here to pimp
your eyes oh my god once you go to the
police your turn to do the guy